[Music]
I'm Michael dasa and I'm a creative best
way to play Hey in a nutshell his name
was originally Shaq
he's a depiction of you know just my
observation of let's say a road man
you know growing up in London a young
person that's on the street and trying
to just kind of find his hand at
whatever to do you know take himself out
of his negative circumstances and turn
it into something positive
many more are aware in the cubicle
magnums render queue bazooka you know
there's a kolyan thing certain times
some proper funny things that happened
on set and I've just had to hold it
together you know okay you know that's
what Shaq does good you know it just
holds it together wherever you kill me
cuz he doesn't really love like that
yeah it was yeah I think it is you know
especially we like mockumentary style
comedy yeah you get one take one shot
and like if I'm to laugh during that
shot you've missed a moment yeah yeah
yeah the little II
our today's bonus the portrait either
yeah Italian oh okay
nothing okay all right yeah I figured
out that he's somebody that people have
just generally seen in real life you
know I'm saying and I think that's
probably what's made him become me you
know this the kind of standout character
you know I mean he's a funny guy you
know I'm saying he's got he got elements
of banner there's realism in it and I
think just the combination of you know
being able to bring the realism the
background and mixing them together to
be able to create you know the character
that you have today is what made him so
popular